And so, if we're going to
talk about all the elements,
we'd better have a handle on
how many elements there are.
So, how would you deal with that?
>> We could use some variable, I guess,
to represent the number of
elements in the vector, say N.
That would work.
>> Okay, and
are there any limits on the value, then?
>> No, I don't think so.
>> Well,
it better be non-negative, right?
>> Right, right, yes.
>> It wouldn't make sense to have
a vector of negative length.
So, we're going to,
when we talk about all the elements, and
the typical element is going
to be in the ith position.
The value of i is going to
go up to this value of n.
And, of course, with programming
languages, you have to worry about
whether they start counting from zero,
or they start counting from one.
And here, we'll say that
we start counting from one.
That is the first element of
the vector using position one.
And then,
the subsequent elements go up to
the last one then being in position n.
So, if there are n elements in the
vector, and we are talking about all but
the last, that says we're talking
about from position one to n minus 1.
>> Right.
>> Okay?
>> And
we want to have some property
that's true about that.
And you said that the property was that,
if we look at that position and
get the value in that vector,
it's less than or
equal to the value in the next position.
>> Correct.
>> Okay.
So if we're going from one to n minus 1,
and
n is initially 0, isn't that asking
us to look in the position minus 1?
>> I guess n can't be negative,
but couldn't
we write it in such a way that we say,
i, and then i plus 1?
So, we could start at zero,
and then go to one?
>> Well,
I think we have the same problem there.
>> Okay.
>> But, what we're trying to do is make
some statement for all i,
i being from one to n minus 1.
If n is zero,
then we're saying from all i,
from one to minus 1, and
there aren't any i there.
So vacuously, it's true.
Okay?
So, even though we run into this
seemingly nonsensical situation,
it doesn't actually effect
the truth of the post condition.
Okay?
So, think about that a little bit.
And given that, we're then allowed to
make this quantified statement for
all i, from one to n minus 1.
And what must be true of each
of those i possibilities?
You're talking about the output.
>> This doesn't get any easier.
[LAUGH].
But we have [INAUDIBLE].
Okay, so y of i is less than or
equal to, or no.
We're going to do an i minus 1.
So it's going to be greater than or
equal to y of minus 1.
>> Nope.
I think you had it right the first time.
>> Oh.
>> If i is starting at one, okay,
then we're going to be talking about and
we're going to n minus 1.
We're going to be going
to y sub i plus 1.
>> Okay.
>> Okay, so you might want
to change your slide there.
Okay.
So what it means to be ordered is,
if we look at the first n minus 1
elements, any one of those, and compare
it to the one next to it on the right,
it's got to be less than or equal to it.
And if we have that property,
then we say that the output is ordered.
Notice, that we didn't say anything
in this part of the post condition
about what those y's are and
how they relate to the input.
That's what the second part
of the specification is.
>> Before we move forward, is it okay
to start trying to express things?
This is kind of like predicate
calculus kind of notation.
Is that what we'll be leaning towards
once we start expressing things in OCL?
>> So, in this part of the lesson,
we're going to use first order logic.
It turns out that OCL is just another
syntax on top of first order logic.
Okay?
We're going to stick with first order
logic here.
Eventually, I'll show
you a little bit of OCL.
And then, in later lessons, we'll get
into the whole OCL as a language,
which in addition to first order logic
has some other things that help it deal
with UML.